how do you not have an agent or a
manager but I'm meeting with you
like how is this happening right now
how did you go from making no budget
movies to raising 165
000 ish for cloning yeah so
clowning came about a very interesting
way the horror film we're going to be
going into here soon that picture we
were in the process of building out
talking to different producers executive
executive producers for the horror film
and
casting directors and as we started to
build that project
I I became more detached from it because
the current producers that were there at
that moment they were going around and
talking to investors but they weren't
bringing me to those meetings so out of
a desperation to continue creating I
wrote clowning
and then in the midst of that horror
film I needed to find an entertainment
attorney because these contracts were
going to start coming from these
investors for the horror film
and I needed to be prepared because who
knows what those were going to say and
obviously you just have to have an an
entertainment attorney
so at that time living in West Hollywood
I realized calling entertainment
attorneys around La was going to be much
more expensive most people want you to
put down 20 grand or a larger retainer
on them to come into a feature film and
and so so we didn't have that kind of
capital laying around to get an
entertainment attorney that way so I
called my Uncle who works in
international tax Consulting and just
asked them about getting an
entertainment attorney
so he told me he would call he's in
Atlanta so he contacted a bunch of
different attorneys and he gave me the
name of an individual named Kelly fry
and I called Kelly and we had a
conversation and Kelly informed me that
Not only was he an entertainment
attorney but he was also an executive
producer but his executive producing hat
was tapped
so he'll read the script at that point I
had just finished writing clowning and
he asked me what I was writing I told
him about clowning he said he'd love to
read it
so I sent him clowning
and he told me also he was 20 000 as an
entertainment attorney but he was
willing to take five up front and get
the rest out of the budget so there was
a part of it was like okay well this is
the best deal we've gotten so far so I
sent him clowning to give it a read and
that was on a Friday and on Sunday I get
an email from him no you wouldn't expect
an entertainment attorney to be emailing
you on the weekend so I get this email
and he said it was one of the best
scripts he's ever read he waived his
twenty thousand dollar entertainment fee
uh and also said that he wanted to be
the executive producer of it and wanted
to take a stab at finding the financing
from that point
we end up getting into a couple of
different meetings with other financiers
at one point we had financiers who came
to the table with 250 000 but they
wanted me to replace my lead Jonathan
galleto who's my producing partner
so I didn't want to replace Jonathan
because clowning's based on his life our
love of our friendship and also we love
working together and it was his film his
story really truly to make with him so I
told him no I wasn't gonna you know for
no matter how much money I'm not going
to replace John
so we so he started to try to walk away
from the table and I kept him on the
phone and I said listen I can make this
money I can make this movie for any
amount of money you know you find me
fifty thousand dollars and I'll make
this movie happen so he's like okay let
me talk to a couple other financiers and
then within a month he was able to pull
together 165 000 and we were Off to the
Races with Jonathan starring part of the
the the the
part of the actual deal we struck up was
me cutting 20 Pages out of the script he
was like you either cut 20 Pages out of
the script or replace Jonathan and so I
was like I'll cut the pages which really
thank goodness because we needed to cut
even more pages than that as you find
out when you get into your editing
process and
cutting the movie from 115 minutes down
to 92 minutes
was it were the twi the were they
consecutive 20 Pages or there were
different parts where they didn't all
different parts oh there's different
parts that I I chose to to remove and
you know this this my journey into this
is very interesting because I've had a
ton of freedom so we got these investors
um that brought the money that they
invest in movies often and all very
wealthy individuals and when they
invested it I was already signed on to
be a producer writer director editor
sound designer and then eventually I
mixed the film too but under a pseudo
name
um but what that gave me for better or
worse is having so much freedom on the
process the crazy thing here was we had
a 120 page screenplay
the money wasn't quite enough to do the
film so we ended up having to shoot that
a material in 17 days
so we shot 120 pages over 17 days
it's supposed to be 18 but one of the
days got burnt out by the fire because
there were fires that October and so we
had to cancel one of our days of
shooting so Clowney was such a
treacherous undertaking because it's not
a one location film it's got around 30
to 40 locations throughout the whole
picture there's
60 or so actors in the piece it's
jumping from different time periods and
so it was very complicated with a lot of
makeup changes uh to do this thing in 17
days but I feel like coming through
clowning and using that resources using
the budget to to make that picture it
really helped me figure out the final
steps of making a movie with a big team
because one of the questions they asked
me on set was where do you like to have
your monitor
and at that time I didn't have a direct
answer because I had made all these
movies with the camera on my shoulder
so where would I want to have a monitor
well now I know I want to create a
massive amount of separation
so I want to have a handheld monitor in
the future be next to the camera and the
actors and I want the producing monitor
the monitor for everybody else to be at
a completely different space far away
and I want to try to create this realm
where no one knows when we cut
I'm kind of segwaying into what I want
to do in the future but going back to
cloning and getting that budget it was
the first time I ever was given money
for something I wrote and as we know in
the history of Cinema that's how it used
to work constantly as you'd write
something so good they'd give you some
money and you'd go out and try to see
what you can do with it so I was so
thankful that it came about that way
and it was a crazy crazy
Journey because
the uh you know then we go into covid
and we're in post-production
and so luckily I'm editing and doing all
the sound design myself with a little
four track audio recorder out there
getting all the different sounds and uh
so throughout most of covid I was
finishing clowning myself and having
these private screenings with me and
some of the main collaborators and then
our executive producer
um he just wasn't as much involved in
the selling of the movie so me and my
producing partner had to figure out how
to get the thing out there and build our
own sales package and contacted gravitas
Ventures and was able to get the thing
sold so now coming off of clowning and
paying the taxes every year because one
thing people don't realize is when you
create that LLC every year you got to
pay taxes on it and that could be
thirteen hundred dollars depending on
how many k ones you have to have made
for all your investors
so it's like every time you make an
indie film that you want to make money
on it's an actual company that you're
spending money on every year so then the
the then suddenly we're in the middle of
a pandemic
and the movie I have to finish it myself
so we can get it out there because now
we owe these people my sister's house a
really nice house in Columbus Ohio is
150 000 so we spent more than my
sister's house on this movie and like an
hour in the middle of a pandemic where
people are saying the movie industry's
shifting and changing and but luckily
the movie came out March 15th and it's
on Blu-ray and Best Buy and Walmart and
a bunch of different places so it's
really uh exciting to see that go out
there and so much came for that then for
me clowning demystified the whole
getting money from investors and selling
movies
it's very much now just such a business
and makes sense
and how it works but
so from just your uh Uncle contacting or
or getting you some numbers of
entertainment attorneys yeah and this
individual wasn't even here in La no
Tennessee
and then some of the investors are in
New York other investors are in Florida
and then the gentleman saw the or read
the script over the weekend
said not only do you you know I'm going
to lower my retainer or whatever and
take some of the money he waived his
fees completely for just points yeah
yeah and uh that's great and then and
then a friend of mine who became our
casting director used his agent and his
manager to start contacting
name actors like Mike Starr and Bronson
pen show and people like that I met
Bronson in a meeting and he loved the
script said that it was he had read
something that great since True Romance
I don't know if he really meant that
fully but regardless I took it and it
felt really great to hear that
um but I love True Romance and I don't
think that necessarily but anyways
um
I sat down on Bronson and he's like how
do you not have an agent or a manager
but I'm meeting with you
like how is this happening right now and
is this such a unique moment where the
truth is I came down from San Francisco
to Los Angeles I found an independent
rental house
and I went to this rental house I was in
the middle of a Hollywood production
Center
are you familiar with those where where
you can rent little spaces for riding
rooms and stuff like that so if I went
into a Hollywood production Center and
talked to this individual who owned his
own rental house and convince them to
hire me and then in the production
Hollywood production Center I went
around to every single room and met
everybody in the building I could
and then I called all the clients in
this rental house
and I called each one and I would
pretend like we're missing a lens and I
would segue into conversations and
before I knew it I was first aid on a
little TV show that was uh for a couple
of weeks from doing that and then I met
almost every person that worked on
clowning with me came through the rental
house
and then my friend who used his agent
manager to cast the thing with me
uh had his own
um selfie tapes business inside of the
Hollywood production Center and we would
use their Lobby and we would use their
rooms to do casting for free
so the clowning was built and it looked
like it had a budget early on but for a
couple months we were prepping the thing
and had no clue where the money was
going to come from
and I think that's a big Testament to
the whole scenario and here's a really
scary story
early on we knew the money was coming we
hadn't gotten the money yet but we knew
that we had confirmation it was coming
we had casted Bronson
Mike Starr Dash o'connery nonagana and a
couple of other actors all sag
and I suddenly get an email from the SAG
office in LA and they email me and no
one knows this actually this is
something only a couple of close people
knows this but now that it's out and
it's over and it's all great I can say
it but I got an email and they tried to
shut down our production
they emailed me out of nowhere and said
you're officially a non-sag movie it's
come to our attention you've already
filmed the movie and you're backtracking
to try to become SAG so that you can
sell this movie we hadn't shot a single
frame what happened is I had posted on
my Instagram now I worked at the rental
company I mentioned
and there is a moment where my the owner
of the rental company came to me and
said he just bought an Alexa mini and
some cook anamorphic lenses and he said
go out for the weekend and do some test
shoots with the equipment so I filmed my
friend dressed as a clown because I was
writing clowning this is before we even
got the money oh no no this after we got
the money because we had people locked
or no this is before we got the money
because we were just filming
um when we actually did the test shoot
and and so I post a still frame of him
dressed as a clown and then sag won't
take my call
because I'm trying to explain to them
that that's not from our movie and that
they're just positive because they went
through my Instagram so I decided I I
got on their website I found every
single sag email I could find and I
wrote the most passionate email this you
know talking about how's the fourth
generation from a family that's a fourth
generation paper mill working family
Hamilton Ohio it was Against All Odds
that I would even be in Hollywood let
alone be giving six figures to make my
first you know movie with a budget and I
wrote this passion email and I emailed
it to like 70 people at the SAG building
including some of the people that run
sag
and then I got this email back said for
you know just this once will will make
this sag and from now on make sure that
you never breach any of our rules again
since then I've done a couple of sag
movies and they've been really lovely
but that was terrifying
is that is even shooting a little like
just practice like teaser trailer or
something would that constitute going
into production yes so it does as soon
as you're if you're in Los Angeles and
you're trying to make a movie and you
have any actor that's sag at all then
you have to contact them and let them
know what you're doing if you want to do
a read through if you want to have a
meeting where an actor's already signed
on to your project just to talk
all of those things they could flag and
say that you're not you have to be so
but but on the other side of the fence
though I get it because actors deserve
to be paid for working and so that's
what they're trying to protect
um which was crazy for our picture I had
so many sag actors they told me I paid
all of our actors even better than any
other production at our level because I
wanted to make sure that people are
being paid well and almost our whole
production was most of our money went to
actors another big thing that you don't
know going into making an indie film at
a quarter million dollar budget is that
sag is going to take a deposit so they
took fourteen thousand dollars as a
deposit from us which is not something
you contemplate in your budget with 165
available
so we were almost fourteen thousand
dollars at the end of the budget
at the end of the shoot at the end of
the 17 days we were like almost exactly
fourteen thousand dollars over budget
but we had to come up with that money
ourselves because they won't return that
budget until a month or two after you're
finished shooting
and so you have to deliver that via
cashier's check or how does that oh no
that was wired it's wired yeah and you
have how many days
to get that to them like once they find
out you you're going to production when
is that paid well the deposit side of it
you know once you're totally sealed and
you have your actors and then you send
them your final paperwork that says what
each actor is being paid then they do a
percentage of what the amount is you're
gonna owe actors and then they that
percentage is what they ask you for the
deposit and then I think that has to be
given to them a week or two before you
go into filming
I believe I can't quite recall the exact
timing
and then it's held
there about until a month or two after
you rap wow yeah which is where like I
had to put a loan on my car and some
other things so just make sure because I
mean some of our lead production heads
needed their checks and like and like
for me that's more important than
anything to make sure people are paid
for their great work uh luckily the loan
on my car is already paid off and God
that's good yeah yeah yeah it was but uh
but it was a really stressful moment
coming off that movie and being like
well we got to come up with fourteen
thousand dollars to
get people situated but but also I've
heard now now that I've talked to a lot
of people that have done quarter million
dollar features apparently it's very
normal to go 30 to 40 000 over budget on
a movie like that
so I don't think we've really even
hardly went over budget at all
when it really comes down to it so you
have those expenses plus you're paying
on this LLC yes that do you close out
the LLC once the movie is distributed
it's forever something you're going to
be it's going to be a company
for in for in perpetuities yeah until
until it's uh I guess and then you would
dissolve it later if it stopped making
money okay but but like right now we
have a 10-year deal with gravitas
Ventures so so that movie will be out
there for 10 years and as that 10 years
is going on I got to keep the bank
account alive got to keep the LLC alive
um all those things so then the money
can come through and everybody can get
paid
but you can see how quickly if you made
multiple Independent films and you're
trying to create those vessels in which
you can make money that they could drain
your bank account very fast
if you have a couple of those and you're
making no money
sure but you said if you were making no
money you could theoretically dissolve
yeah the LLC but then that would cut off
all chances of
ever making something from them right so
you have to decide okay is my filmmaking
no money do I cut my losses or do I hold
out hope
interesting wow yeah and then I mean at
the same time I mean now you have
investors you have people who have
really given you money their personal
money from their bank accounts so you
know obviously I walk into this with a
very honest mindset and my main goal is
to get them back their money so
I mean that's one reason why we I mean
we had never sold a movie before going
into clowning so going into cloning we
really had to teach ourselves how to
make a sales package because a lot of
people go to sales representatives
to get their movie off into the world
but a sales representative is going to
take a percentage on top of the
distributor and I've heard horror
stories where you'll never see a penny
so for us it was like well what are they
doing that we can't do and then we built
the sales package and luckily got it out
to gravitas but I mean you know I mean
at the end of the day it really also
depends on who's the lead of your movie
too because unfortunately you do need to
have some kind of
name that people are familiar with to
help them want to go see it I mean if
you want to make movies and put them in
AMC's
which I would like to do
and so with Bronson Pinchot did you
watch perfect strangers growing up oh
yeah most definitely my favorite Bronson
performance that really melted into my
mind's eye like April 23 2006 was when I
decided to start making films well
probably a few years later I discovered
the movie True Romance
and I watched that a billion times so
when I met Bronson the first time and he
came in and talked about True Romance my
mind is like whoa I can't believe this
is you know like eight ten years later
suddenly we're talking about this but
Bronson's unbelievable I wrote a
particular psychological Thriller for
him to star in and I'm hoping that we do
that soon
um he's gotten into an incredible health
and just been a great physical place but
you know he's he's the hands down best
improvisationalists right I've ever seen
I mean just from the show I don't know
how much of that was improv of his
character but hilarious oh he's so
intelligent so funny and uh
and and really is hungry to perform like
if somebody's looking for a great actor
out there Bronson Pinchot is is really
just hungry to keep going
did he stop acting for a while
for a little while there he did he was
renovating houses
yeah he got into it he has a passion to
renovate houses and
to redo things like that himself with
his own hands he'll send me a picture
sometimes of uh
his own little rooms that he was doing
during the pandemic we're somewhere in
Upstate New York I think I saw some yeah
and then he had a little reality show or
something okay maybe that's where I saw
it and they like were following him a
little bit while he was choosing houses
and like choosing how to uh renovate
them but oh that's great yeah but he's
doing a lot of acting now he's
definitely back yeah